This Is wired's 50 most asked questions
that Lord the Rings the rings of power
[Music]
how do the rings of power work with
magic they're not battery powered well
one has nunchucks the other one has a
bug sound we're in trouble already they
can enhance kind of the power that one
already has but they can also corrupt
it's a double-edged sword a ring of
power coach Middle Earth character you I
am Gladwell who is elf from valinor one
of the oldest elves in Middle Earth
older than the moon I play queen regent
midiel and she is the leader of the
island Kingdom of numenor I am dorin I'm
a sailor on the island of niminar called
sildur I'm elendil the tool I am Gil
Gallant King Of The Elves and you know
Giver of numenor
not me who is Galadriel and the Lord of
the Rings she's a very old
um powerful mythical elf and I am
playing her in Livingston who has the
rings of power which ones oh didn't see
that coming did you okay there's like 19
is that you need to read the books I get
a bunch gets one I think she's gonna get
one not a bad guy
spoiler alert
how old is Sauron old old
thousands and thousands thousands since
the beginning of time basically where
was the rings of power filmed in Detroit
New Zealand in and around Auckland and
some location stuff in the South Island
if you were lucky enough does Middle
Earth have bees yes I imagine the
hobbits and the Whole Foods yes say
they're obese yeah but the bees are
enormous how big are dwarves and half
Huts I think we're
three four five four no four foot four
foot and a half or what's shorter would
be softer yeah half foot to smaller that
sounds like a dwarf opinion but if
they're much taller than my stool is
lower than everyone else's on this table
so I feel a little bit like a half foot
pound dog here
I think we are um
well I mean he you know I had joint
problems
Lord of the Rings so Moodle is where
Sauron resides during the third Age full
of fire and darkness I mean if you think
about it brimbor is a Lord and he makes
the ring so in my opinion
how many kingdoms in Middle Earth second
age okay let's list them then done
Kingdom of numeral yes Kingdom
[Music]
good question I mean I'm going with the
more yeah the Orcs yeah
who is Valar it should be who are The
Velo like Mount Olympus you've got Zeus
which would be louvitar and beneath him
are the kind of Demi guys with your
other Valor sort of like Angels right
what is an Orcs a baddie well he
originally wasn't enough a foreign elf
all goes back to the elves who is Elmont
in Lord of the Rings he's related to me
he's a half elf who chose to be an elf
instead of a human could you see the
Judgment in the pure elf there about the
half I felt it how many Lord of the
Rings shows are there just one I mean
there's ours
a few cartoons there's some films some
games some radio please what's a hard
foot it's a small person they're a Proto
type of a Hobbit yeah like a predecessor
emotional kind and brave who directed
The Lord of the Rings shows we have
three incredible directors
Wayne yep and Charlotte brenstrom
marvelous who is melkor the origin of
evil or the dragon in Neverending Story
although that's Falcor is Hobbit Lord of
the Rings I would say yes to that yeah
definitely it's the original book The
J.R Tolkien wrap the book of The Hobbit
set before the Lord of the Rings
can there only be one Lord for all Rings
yes well I'd say the baddy things yeah
and I would agree with him Sauron wants
to be the Lord of the Rings he made one
to make himself the Lord of the Rings
but he's lost it how small are elves are
very small that's a bit passive
aggressive how small are elves
how Grand our elves I'll accept does the
ring give you Powers Yeah
superpowers you can fly I'm joking are
there Wars and battles in Lord of the
Rings the rings of power yes yes what
are the races of Middle Earth elves
dwarves and humans who are human Spirits
special humans superhumans the uh
horrified yeah goblins balrogs not
really a race though are they imagine if
we're all wrong
we've enjoyed being in the show how long
is the second age three two three
thousand years almost four thousand
years long but very adventurous who
wrote The Lord of the Rings three two
one
juror Tolkien where does Lord of the
Rings take place takes place in Middle
Earth which is part of order why is
Sauron mad
he's power hungry he wants it all for
himself he's after absolute power he
doesn't think he's mad that's what's
scary well we never do when does Lord of
the Rings take place well there's a
first second and third Age The Lord of
the Rings takes place in the third age
which is thousands of years after our
show where's Middle Earth in Adam bang
in the middle of the road succinctly put
um yeah
yeah all right
yeah in The Lord of the Rings of rings
power who arrives in Middle Earth via
Comet a stranger a strange man I mean
stranger is that the nobody the nobody
what source of power did Kell brimborg
use to create the rings of power
Pizza thank you he built a forge as hot
as dragon's breath and as bright as a
star ah Lord of the Rings Elves Immortal
yes they are they are however it's not
quite as simple as they live forever
because they sometimes die and then they
go to the halls of Mandos where they
have to wait a bit and then they get
come back into a new body is that
correct or is it the same body though I
don't know I stopped listening
came back are there Wizards in the rings
of power watch and see
what's Middle Earth race are you you get
this wrong
Army dwarf we're human audience proud
Newman audience yes only because the
elves gave them the place
how much did the kings of numenor know
about the rings of power zip I don't
think they knew anything yeah until
farazon decides he was more powerful
than everyone else and then they
ultimately became an article so it
wasn't a good ending when is the second
age after the first and before the third
what is Middle Earth made of dirt no
above I got the question wrong you've
made up the ocean surrounded by the
sundering Seas what's what's to the east
of it all the way all the way all the
way to these because I don't think it's
surrounded I don't think it's an island
is it the ocean it is
in the middle of water what is the new
Lord of the Rings about it's about the
rings of power it's the quintessential
battle between good and evil also about
different groups coming together for
common cause the common cause of
defeating evil I like the idea of that
who's the most powerful person in The
Lord of the Rings Universe don't don't
jump too quickly guys
I think you have to watch the show to
see that one what is Sauron doing in
second age being naughty yeah devious
growing yes did the elves blame Keller
brimbor for making the rings of power I
mean they feel conflicted about it he
he's so quickly punished for doing it
that I think casting blame at that point
is pretty ruthless how big is mid left
it's pretty vast huge take you a long
time on a horse to travel across who are
the bad guys in Lord of the Rings rings
of power you could make the the case
that the Orcs in particular are the bad
guys but you know it's a conflicted uh
issue okay our elves and humans friends
it's complicated definitely on the
island of numenor there's a Schism
happening if you're a numenorian you
might not be too keen on an elf because
they live forever and we don't and we're
a bit jealous of that fact who is
elendio me I'm melindale and Lyndale is
the father of seildur and founder of the
kingdom of Gondor why it with the rings
of power created to match an outfit well
they were created by Sauron to control
Middle Earth to to one entity no he only
created the one to control those Rings
oh but why were the rings of power
created to save Middle Earth basically
just kind of save save the elves what
are the Misty Mountains where the
dwarves live where do the elves live in
the woods who is this little door here's
lindell's son me
potentially a problem child why is it
called Middle Earth it was something
that Tolkien was playing with around
about the Middle Ages idea that somehow
it gives it a time that is Fantastical
and yet rooted in some sort of
historical reality we made it through 50
questions yeah how do you think we did
fine I enjoyed that yeah it was really
good I love talking talking and you guys
are incredibly fun and really good I
mean we could have stayed here for hours
we've probably got 30 30 I'm sure as a
cast we had to dial them beautifully
thanks for watching